the scp foundation is well aware of the
thin line separating itself between
normalcy and the end of the human race
how easily that balance can be upset and
the foundation overturned without the
foundation we may be subject to any
number of scenarios that may result in
our untimely extinction the reign of the
scarlet king ready to enslave the world
once more the assimilation of the broken
god an ascension of humanity into a most
perfect machine the scp foundation is
often outmatched and outnumbered
competing against ancient unspeakable
horrors but those anomalies are well
known one could almost say that they're
built up and that the foundation knows
the risks that can lie ahead in the
future in other words they have time to
prepare but when dealing with the
anomalous the unexpected is bound to
occur it's part of what the scp
foundation deals with and an element of
their work they've forever been unable
to control or predict the anomalous is
untamed it occurs without rhyme or
reason in the world of the scp
foundation it is entirely possible you
might wake up and find that everyone
around you has died or that the world's
been consumed by an evil unseen force
and there would be nothing you can do
about it it happened and not even the
foundation was able to stop it perhaps
the overabundance and unpredictability
of the world is why the foundation
deemed it necessary to build
scp-2000 the machine capable of
restarting civilization from scratch
death and mass destruction is always at
the door of the foundation and sometimes
they are unable to prevent it we've
previously looked at the tale of pietro
wilson who found himself in a world
devastated by an unknown entity but
scp-5000 is far from the only time the
foundation has dealt with the anomalous
apocalypse today we're going to be
telling a story of scp-1915
and an entity known only as the absence
it's a story you may not have heard
before and like all stories involving
the scp foundation and the end of the
world we look forward to telling it for
centuries civilizations have been
predicting the end of the world from the
mayans to the ancient greeks to the
biblical end is nigh preachers of today
humanity seems obsessed with trying to
figure out the when and how of its
extinction but when the date eventually
comes we all find ourselves in the exact
same place healthy and alive none of us
actually expect such an event to happen
and if it did most of us realized that
we wouldn't be among the survivors who
could witness the world after it was
empty but for
scp-1915 that was not the case
scp-1915 stood alone in the desert
listening to the silence of the evening
sunset if he hadn't known what had
happened to the world he could call the
scene beautiful or serene he might find
it pure but he couldn't allow himself to
enjoy the calming vistas not after what
he had witnessed he knew what lies
beneath and among the sands of that
desert he knew the feeling of seven
billion human souls being ground up
stretched thin and buried below without
any trace of their existence remaining
and he knew this was because he was the
only one who put them there it's quiet
out here
scp-1915 thought to himself oh brother
it all happened so fast once we're gone
but let's turn back the clock a bit who
is scp-19
how did he get himself into this
situation the foundation's database
holds the answers
scp-1915 was a humanoid entity contained
in a standard humanoid chamber which it
had modified itself
scp-1915's containment procedures stated
that furniture and sustenance were
unnecessary as scp-1915 provided both of
them itself
scp-1915 looked like a completely
average middle-aged white male the type
you'd pass by on the street and neglect
to notice he was of unexceptional build
and height and public records gave him
an equally unexceptional name which has
been lost due to years of the
foundation's redaction and information
suppression thankfully for the
foundation a background check into
scp-1915 civilian life revealed no
friends or relatives meaning that
removing
scp-1915 from society was as easy as it
first appeared
scp-1915 is so far relatively
unremarkable and that's entirely the
point
scp-1915's anomalous nature lies in its
ability to prevent any significant
long-term change to its body personality
memory or lifestyle
scp-1915 is also a reality bender and it
will actively alter the world around it
to maintain its personal status quo
though these alterations are largely
limited to non-living matter
manipulation and mental manipulations as
far as reality benders go
scp-1915 is relatively weak as it is
unable to permanently affect living
creatures with its anomalous abilities
other than itself what makes
scp-1915 especially interesting and
especially dangerous as well is the fact
that it is entirely unaware of its own
anomalous nature its mild discontent
expressed in interviews with the
foundation suggested to the organization
that
scp-1915 has little if any control over
its own abilities scp-1915
is due to its anomalous nature entirely
unaware of its containment as being
locked up by the scp foundation would
definitely be a significant long-term
change in fact it still believes that it
is employed by a corporation and working
a mundane office job where the
foundation recovered scp-1915
originally
scp-1915 cannot bring itself to accept
its situation and has instead
unconsciously altered its mine and
containment cell accordingly to scp-1915
absolutely nothing has changed during
its initial recovery from its office job
scp-1915 altered the mobile task force's
armored vehicle into a city bus and
convinced itself that the operatives
escorting it were simply other civilians
on their commute to work once it arrived
at site-17
scp-1915 converted its containment cell
into an exact replica of its apartment
complete with electronic devices akin to
the ones it owned running water and
sewage access it even assumed the other
researchers and guards inside the
facility were neighbors or local service
workers the morning following its
containment
scp-1915 left its cell despite it being
locked and entered a maintenance closet
the closet was transformed into a
recreation of the office cubicle
scp-1915 worked in prior to being
contained when foundation researchers
tried to communicate with scp-1915
it apologized for coming after hours to
finish the budget report claiming that
it needed the extra income during an
interview with the foundation
scp-1915 still couldn't accept its
situation instead it believed that it
was being referred to by name despite
being referred to as
scp-1915 and that it was still working
an office job it displayed remorse that
it was passed over for a promotion yet
again and asked the interviewer if it
was working on the third floor
scp-1915 was completely and utterly
unable to view reality outside of its
own lens sure he's able to alter reality
but he's entirely unaware of it in a way
the only thing keeping
scp-1915 chained to that soul-sucking
office job is itself and its inability
to accept anything different what a
metaphor right but how could
scp-1915 defy reality in the face of the
world ending would he still believe that
he's working away at a budget report or
grabbing coffee for his boss when the
world's burning around him let's move
back to the desert scene where
scp-1915 is standing before an empty
world seemingly holding itself
responsible for ridding the earth of
humanity scp-19
recollects what occurred the events
leading up to this moment he thinks of
what happened when staring outside the
windows of its containment cell
apartment
scp-1915 remembers what it saw he began
the day you you that i have never known
found my power the power i hid for
myself in some previous life for reasons
i can now easily guess i was looking out
of the window of my apartment so i could
see the stars and instead i saw you
blazing as you tore yourself asunder to
keep the power away from yourself you
didn't trust what you would do with it
and so you chose to throw it away you
knew yourself all too well and i suspect
i did too at one point by all accounts i
should not have been able to see you for
my apartment was truly a tiny
containment cell about a half mile
underground but such considerations
never meant much to one living entity in
his own world when i saw the moment of
your demise i became aware of myself for
the first time and i have no idea in how
long whichever part of me that led me to
throw away my power did the same to my
will trapping it in an internal status
quo for which there could be no release
an eternity of filing spreadsheets for
employers who existed solely in my head
of nine o'clock meetings with no one
have fake crushes over imaginary women
an eternity of tired grinding mediocrity
but that was over that night with your
soul burning in the atmosphere like the
loneliest of stars i awakened i died
whatever scp 1915 saw that day made it
aware of the farce of a life that it had
created for itself and beneath those
feelings of conformity there was sadness
for whatever left that little cell
turned apartment wasn't me anymore i was
never more than an earthworm distinct
from all the rest only that i had a
little more control over the soil in
which i crawled they never thought me
more than a minor reality bender a
bundle of introverted powers and
neuroses that was very unlikely to ever
pose any serious threat and they were
right the person i was scp 1915 as they
called me never was anything other than
that but 1915 died that day watching a
falling star realizing that it had been
cheated lied to and the crushing reality
of its current situation
scp-1915 lashed out against the
foundation the thing that then swatted
the guards posed at its cell like they
were little less than gnats the raised
site-17 into this fine white sand that
was now so warm beneath the feet that
was something else not an entity for
that would imply a personality and this
thing surely has none not a purpose for
there was no purpose behind its action
then nor will there be for any of its
actions to come nor was it a will for
wants nothing not vengeance not dominion
not freedom not even simple power no if
i had to describe that thing as anything
at all it would be
an absence a void where the entity
should be a lack of purpose an imbecile
force devoid of all will and absence
scp-1915 had in its realization become
an absence perhaps realizing the
meaninglessness of its own
self-contained life it took out that
absence of feeling onto the world and
with
scp-1915's absence came humanity's
absence as well like nothing had ever
happened
scp-1915 had created an absence of
humanity it had erased everything but
the sun the desert and itself and now
it's stood alone in an empty lonely
world it continued to think to itself
remembering how it caused the downfall
of the scp foundation so easily after
site 17's destruction retaliation soon
followed standard containment teams at
first though certainly still enough to
meet any anomaly the foundation imagined
could be contained in site-17 with
overwhelming force when those men failed
to return fail to even report to their
arrival more serious measures had to be
taken site-17 has always been isolated
and so they could act freely gun ships
and fire teams aerial bombardment and
artillery barrages the foundation came
down on what it's still believed to be
scp-1915 like a fire god's fist all heat
and sound and bluster had it still been
truly corporeal i doubt even ashes would
have remained but whatever the absence
truly was by that point the tattered
semblance of my flesh hanging around it
had very little to do with it it simply
stood there and took it all in and the
foundation's initial fury was soon
spent it then began to walk and not too
quickly either for days it simply
leisurely strode on while the foundation
threw everything it had of it i watched
from within my deadbolt as it walked
unfeeling uncaring and this desert
followed in its wake as inscrutiable and
unstoppable as its harbinger while the
foundation and the rest of humanity were
decimated quite easily there was some
immortal beings that scp-1915 was aware
it could not fully erase other anomalies
that the foundation had contained
somewhat but they were all but remained
tied to a dead and desolate world as cp
1915's memories continued when someone
walks they're bound to reach somewhere
eventually despite everyone's best
efforts and so the absence arrived at
its first city the sands at its heels
like an obedient lap dog oh there have
been villages and towns before that but
the absence didn't seem to care enough
to bother with them it simply walked by
leaving them to the whims of the sands
which were only ever singular in their
intent but through the streets of the
city it strode as mobile task forces
fought and fell to buy the civilian
population just a few more minutes to
evacuate by this point hiding what was
truly going on became impossible of
course as street after street sank
beneath the gentle crawling tide the
foundation had of course attempted to
evacuate the city once it realized there
was no stopping the absence but if i've
learned anything in my
eons as a corporeal peon is that
organizing an operation of that
magnitude is something that takes a lot
more time than the foundation had it's
wonder they managed to save as many as
they did city to city town to town scp
1915 continued on a warpath turning its
surroundings to dust the earth became
the desert that it now stood in in one
moment a city of five hundred thousand
existed and the next it didn't
scp-1915 could not explain it instead it
simply was and was not the foundation as
scp-1915 recalled was becoming desperate
and it began to turn to various groups
of interest for help it was then i
believe that the foundation realized
that it could not stand alone the next
few months of the absence's march saw
them turn to their sometimes allies
coalition mage killers and thermonuclear
strikes initiative paladins and holy
relics sniper rifle or sacred sword
burning inferno or divine retribution
the absence did not care and soon the
foundation had no allies left to turn to
he then called on its once vicious
enemies inc eaters wove their art in
maddening patterns to break the minds of
the infinite archivists and librarians
poured from the ways bringing with them
the knowledge of a hundred thousand
worlds clockwork titans shook the barren
whiteness of the sands with the thunder
of metal the absence did not care and
soon the foundation ran out of enemies
in an act of desperation they then
committed their most painful betrayal
the wardens unleashed upon the world
they're prisoners of these i have made
note though i doubt the absence to the
same with the anomalous objects it once
contained now released the foundation
used its own scp objects against
scp-1915 in an effort to stop the entity
from destroying the world itself
scp-1915 recalled fighting against
scp-073 and scp-076
the brothers kane and abel it recalled
scp-343
the entity claiming to be the abrahamic
god launching an assault of
earth-shattering destruction and divine
wrath but 343 nor the brothers were able
to match
scp-1915 when they stared into
scp-1915's lack of a gaze they all faded
into nothing much like the rest of the
world that had turned to dust as a
result of the absence
scp-1915 then recalled encountering two
forms of scp-2845
the god panglos both of which were
powerful mighty and all-consuming but
they had form and their being knelt
before
scp-1915 like everything else did the
absence withstood their presence like it
had done with everything before them for
years the foundation continued to send
every anomaly in its possession after
scp-1915 but they paled in comparison to
the power of the absence and eventually
the foundation was out of anomalies the
foundation was out of time as well
scp-1915's march to the ends of the
earth brought it to a single remaining
human settlement a coalition of
survivors that had cooped themselves up
in hopes of outrunning the entity some
were former agents of the foundation
others were members of various groups of
interest but as you might have expected
they didn't hold a candle to scp-1915
in an act of defiance against the world
that it had been keeping itself from
scp-1915 wiped the city from the earth
and then
it was truly alone and now all
scp-1915 had to do was think back to
what had occurred and how much longer
the rest of the universe had before it
too
succumbed to the absence quiet small
bereft of heroics and great deeds free
of pretensions of great meaning one
night there was a human race on the
planet earth the next there wasn't and
that was that the stars do not wait for
you brother when you took my power when
you burned yourself in the skies above
they looked upon you
and felt nothing the stars did not wait
for humanity for all the promise it
showed for all the promise others saw in
them but what of the absence what of me
we are i am by all accounts and possible
qualifications the greatest monster this
world has ever saw perhaps that any
world saw and yet brother i see now that
the stars wait for us for me where is
the justice in that seek it not for
there is none but the fact remains
brother the stars do not wait for you
but they wait for me to take them into
my embrace i suspect i shall not be long
now go check out
scp-001 the world's gone beautiful and
scp-xk class end-of-the-world scenarios
explain for more of the end of the world
scp stories to help you prep for the end
times